You Yank yours off and put on The Ledger
nah I'm going down with the wait
really you just keep the noise yeah I
mean I I've read the news and this is
the thing like there's a lot of people
who are all upset about a whole bunch of
different things you know when I said
Yankees off I mean like put it on your
own private nah you kissed
like the things that I had on the
platforms right because you gotta
remember like I've worked with we had
advertising deals with some of these
people and like on this case it appears
to be that it was misleading or
fraudulent they tricked a lot of people
that are way smarter than me but it's
not the end of the day it's like yo if
people are going down
right and so I left it on there and like
we'll see what happens
yeah but but gentlemen
privilege to play with you tonight